200 branches will close to bring the
bank into the 21st century those
affected a split in two 76 year old
James is one example would you say use
more online or more of going into bangor
going to bag it's more convenient for me
21 year-old steven another got the app
on the phone so i just use that and do
pay transfers money for that james
mainly uses Lloyd's branches I think
it's complicated for some people because
for start off not everybody's got a
computer right and I know where people
use a mobile phones today but it isn't
for all the people is it so again i
would miss de la about Steven only uses
his mobile phone for online banking how
many people go in the bank most people's
go online or use the phone any go in if
we need to have got a lot more than like
your limit cash at the only of time I'm
going need to draw a lot more than women
he surprised it's taken them maybe this
long to to sort of think about this just
I'll bring it into the 21st century as
they put it not really like to drag
things out a shift towards digital means
virtual advice and less traditional
face-to-face
you